[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravie de vous retrouver
dans Parlement Hebdo l'émission
parlementaire de fin de semaine on va
revoir les séquences fortes à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat avec
notre invité Alexandre bonjour à tous on
accueil aujourd'hui Guillaume Gontard
sénateur de l'Isère et président du
groupe écologiste au Sénat bonjour
bonjour Merci et on va parler de cet
incident de séance rarissime la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale a
interrompu les questions d'actualité
après une injure raciste prononcée dans
l'hémicycle
le Sénat examine le projet de loi sur
les énergies renouvelables objectifs la
neutralité carbone en 2050 en
développant notamment le solaire et les
éoliennes
et puis les députés ont examiné de leur
côté la loi de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur le texte de
Gérald Darmanin prévoit une hausse de 15
milliards d'euros sur 5 ans
enfin le débat sur les retraites qui
s'invite à nouveau au Sénat La droite
majoritaire à proposer de reculer l'âge
de départ à la retraite
et on commence par cette insulte raciste
de la part d'un député RN à l'Assemblée
nationale alors qu'une question au
gouvernement était posée par le député
insoumis à Carlos Martin belongo sur le
sauvetage des migrants en mer Grégoire
de Fournas a crié je cite qui le
retourne en Afrique provoquant un tollé
retour sur cette séquence les personnes
secourues se trouvent aux situations
d'urgence absolue des prévisions météo
indiquent une décoration significative
du climat
pas du tout
c'est
[Applaudissements]
quel est le député qui vient de
prononcer cette phrase
pardon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est pas possible
[Applaudissements]
suspension de séance de 5 minutes
une attitude
infâme infâme dire dans cette émission
de l'Assemblée nationale on puisse
encore avoir des propos aussi racistes
le vernis en train de craquer tout
simplement c'est ça le rassemblement
national aujourd'hui extrême droite à
montrer son vrai visage nous ne
laisserons pas passer un délit comme
celui que vient de faire ce député dans
l'assemblée qui humilie un nombre de
gens dans ce pays par millions qui
n'auraient pas selon le rassemblement
national qui adore trier les joueurs
selon leur couleur de peau cela leur
l'ont religion réel ou supposée sont
leurs genre ou je ne sais quoi je
parlais du bateau pasteur de migrants
voilà que les choses soient très claires
nous sommes en face d'une manipulation
de la France insoumise qui cherche à
dénaturer mes propos pour me faire tenir
des propos dégueulasses vis-à-vis d'un
collègue député député français natation
qui a la même légitimité que moi si j'ai
dans ces bancs
Guillaume Gontard on l'a entendu un
député rassemblement national c'est
défendu en disant qu'il parlait du
bateau de migrants en mer et pas du
député de la France insoumise quel est
votre réaction après cet incident à
l'Assemblée
moi je pensais pas un jour et là se voir
ça à l'Assemblée nationale des propos
racistes parce que c'est ce sont des
propos racistes et le racisme est un
délit je pense que c'est quand même bien
de le rappeler c'est interdit donc
j'espère qu'il y aura non seulement des
sanctions de la part de la part de ce
députés à l'Assemblée nationale mais je
pense qu'il faudra aussi qu'il y ait des
poursuites par rapport à ces paroles
profondément racistes humiliante et qui
sont totalement inacceptables mais je
pense qu'il y a aussi quand même
derrière tout ça une responsabilité
cette responsabilité de vouloir
banaliser le rassemblement national
comme si c'était un parti comme les
autres non le rassemblement national on
le voit et on le savait est un parti
raciste donc il y a aussi une
responsabilité de tous ceux qui ont
voulu notamment dire la nuque le
rassemblement nation c'est la même chose
qui ont permis quand même parce que je
note quand même que ce député comment il
a été élu il a été élu dans une
circonscription où la candidate je crois
en marche n'a pas appelé à voter n'a pas
su se décider et n'a pas appelé à voter
contre ce personnage donc le pour
revenir à ce qui a été prononcé le
compte-rendu officiel de l'Assemblée
nationale ne permet pas de dire si il
faisait référence aux députés à la fille
ou au bateau
donc dans les deux cas pour vous c'est
finalement ce sont des propriétés
évidemment ce sont des propos racistes
même si s'adresse mais vous rendez
compte même si s'adresse aux bateaux à
des personnes qui qui se battent pour
leur pour leur survie et qu'on leur dit
rentrer chez eux retourner en Afrique et
en plus de voilà c'est forcément
évidemment raciste ce sont des propos
racistes qui ne peuvent pas être tenus
dans une assemblée nationale donc je
pense qu'il faut être très clair
là-dessus et puis je suis pas dupe sur
ce que ce monsieur a voulu a voulu
prononcer donc il faut il faut arrêter
c'est c'est quelque chose de totalement
illégal de totalement inacceptable
est-ce que Gérald Darmanin aujourd'hui
trouve que le rassemblement était un peu
trop molle trop mou dans ses dans ces
paroles non mais on est dans quelque
chose de totalement ferme évidemment et
surtout responsable responsable et que
entre républicains on soit quand même
d'accord pour pointer du doigt un parti
qui est profondément raciste mais ce que
ça pose pas un problème quand même que
le rassemblement national vote d'émotion
de censure déposée par la gauche et je
dirais que c'est leur problème c'est
leur problème je vais dire à ce moment
là ça veut dire qu'on ne dépose plus ni
amendement ni quoi que ce soit c'est
leur problème nous on sait exactement où
on est
républicain et voilà il y a pas je
dirais un millimètre de de points
communs avec ce parti alors le bateau
SOS Méditerranée qui abrite près de 234
migrants et lui toujours en mer l'Italie
de Meloni refuse de l'accueillir est-ce
que la France doit le faire pour vous
mais évidemment et vous parlez de
mélodie on est quand même dans une
situation qui est particulièrement grave
entre ces propos qui sont tenus de
manière quasi excès quand même ce qui se
passe en Italie quand même ou des
néo-facias sont au pouvoir un ministre a
été nommé quelques temps avant il avait
un brassard
fasciste donc avec une croix gammée donc
je pense qu'il faut quand même remettre
les choses à leur place sur la question
de du bateau et de ces personnes
évidemment ce sont des personnes qui
sont en danger bien sûr qu'on a cette
responsabilité de les accueillir de les
protéger ça me paraît une évidence
totale allez direction le Sénat puisque
les sénateurs examinent cette semaine le
projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables un texte qui est censé
accélérer le développement notamment des
éoliennes et des panneaux
photovoltaïques au départ la majorité de
droite du Sénat voulait instaurer ce
qu'on appelle un droit de veto des
maires pour s'opposer à l'implantation
d'éoliennes sur le territoire de leur
commune mais au final après la
discussion avec le gouvernement et bien
un compromis a été trouvé les
explications d'Audrey
l'objectif du texte qu'ils examinent ces
deux simplifier l'implantation des
énergies renouvelables pourtant hier les
sénateurs ont dû s'accrocher pour tout
comprendre je pose une question toute
simple le maire a-t-il un droit de veto
si j'ai bien compris moi je vous suivrai
mais j'ai besoin d'être conforté dans ce
que je crois avoir compris je vous
remercie pour éclaircir les choses il
faut revenir au travail en commission
les élus LR décident d'accorder un droit
de veto pour les mers cela doit leur
permettre de s'opposer à un projet
d'énergie renouvelable l'implantation
d'un parc éolien par exemple et de ne
plus être mis devant le fait accompli
l'objectif permettre une meilleure
acceptabilité de ses projets qui
exacerbe bien souvent les tensions
problème certains mers n'en veulent pas
ils se retrouveraient dans tous les cas
seuls sous une autre forte pression ah
ça s'ajoute le fait que des amendements
du Gouvernement permettent aussi au
maire de définir des zones où il
souhaite implanter des énergies
renouvelables en leur le dernier mot sur
ces projets dégage qui ont poussé les
sénateurs LR à renoncer au droit de veto
j'anticipe d'ores et déjà un avis de
sagesse dans la mesure où la vie
conforme est intégrée sera intégrée
demain dans la planification la ministre
a salué la qualité du dialogue avec les
oppositions avant de promettre de
rééclaircir encore cette partie du texte
on prendra le temps de retravailler
l'ensemble du texte mais en ayant cette
logique de planification que nous
appelons de nos vœux l'objectif selon la
ministre faire en sorte que ce texte ne
soit pas une usine à gaz trop complexe
pour les élus des territoires
Guillaume Gontard on va revenir dans un
instant sur cette question du droit de
veto des meilleures faces aux éoliennes
mais d'abord votre avis à la vie du
groupe écologiste du Sénat vis-à-vis de
ce texte du Gouvernement qui est censé à
développer accélérer l'implantation des
énergies renouvelables vous êtes
favorable sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables évidemment qu'on
est fortable et je pense que il faut il
y a une vraie responsabilité il faut
qu'on aille vite on est dans une
situation particulièrement grave sur la
question énergétique on se demande
encore comment on va pouvoir passer
l'hiver et que on n'a pas 36000
solutions quels sont les possibilités
pour pouvoir je dirais produire de
l'électricité rapidement ces énergies
renouvelables il y en a pas d'autres que
ça soit le solaire que ça soit que ça
soit le l'éolien ou d'autres énergies
renouvelables et puis bon évidemment
l'autre aspect la sobriété c'est à dire
consommer moins donc on a on a ces deux
ces deux possibilités là et donc oui il
faut booster après à savoir est-ce que
ce texte va permettre au bout du compte
de réellement booster est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment une volonté du gouvernement
derrière ça je dirais que quand je vois
les débats j'en doute un petit peu je
note quand même la préparation quand
même le flou artistique dans lequel on
est on a vu les débats hier soir qui
était quand même je pense un manque de
préparation un manque de cadrage réel et
puis une position des républicains alors
il faut un petit peu marche arrière
parce que je pense que ça commence à se
voir ça commence à se voir que je dirais
leur irresponsabilité par rapport à la
situation dans lequel on est et de
donner un droit de veto au maire
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire j'étais maire
d'une d'une commune je sais un petit peu
ce que c'est et donc il y a rien contre
les mères mais est-ce qu'on va donner la
politique énergétique de notre pays
juste un maire d'une commune et qui va
décider pour les autres puisque le
gouvernement a fait sauter ce droit de
veto lors du débat ce jeudi le
dispositif a été très assoupli les mers
choisiront des zones prioritaires on l'a
dit dans leur commune pour développer
des éoliennes est-ce que ce compromis
vous satisfait on va dire que c'est un
mieux évidemment enfin je veux dire ce
droit de veto de façon il était pour
nous une ligne rouge en équipe qui
permet de toute façon ne puisse pas
voter ce texte là avec ce droit de
plutôt puisqu'en gros ça tuait
totalement le développement des énergies
renouvelables et notamment des éoliennes
avec cette zone prioritaire
d'implantation oui ça veut dire que on
va dire aux collectivités et je trouve
que c'est plutôt intéressant de
réfléchir à l'implantation en arabe une
planification nationale et puis ensuite
cette implantation au niveau local en
disant je définis des hommes
prioritaires mais les maires pourront
dire bah non moi je veux pas de zone
d'implantation prioritaire soit sauf que
ça veut dire qu'il retourne je dirais
dans le droit commun et ce qui veut pas
dire qu'ils n'auront pas d'éoliennes sur
leur territoire donc moi ce que je dis
Homère c'est au contraire prenez vos
responsabilités réfléchissez sur le
territoire oui on a besoin de répartir
des énergies renouvelables que ça soit
solaire que ça soit éolien il faut le
faire de manière intelligente sur
l'ensemble du territoire à l'échelle
intercommunale évidemment c'est
évidemment que c'est pas à l'échelle de
la commune sinon on va avoir un maire
qui ne va pas vouloir sur sa commune et
puis le maire d'à côté qui va en mettre
en limite en limite communale vous voyez
bien que ça n'a aucun sens donc on doit
avoir cette réflexion à l'échelle de la
de l'intercommunalité et puis et puis
prendre en main et effectivement qu'on
est des zones prioritaires pour dire
nous on souhaite que ça soit à tel
endroit pour tel ou tel ou telle raison
oui ça va dans le bon sens mais à
condition que les élus prennent la main
et notamment à travers des documents
d'urbanisme je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
on a quasi 10000 on a quasi 10000
communes qui sont en règlement national
d'urbanisme ça veut dire que ils n'ont
pas de document d'urbanisme ni plu ni P8
et donc ils n'ont pas la main sur ce qui
se trace sur leur territoire alors
Guillaume Gontard il y a un autre point
de tension d'achoppement entre la
majorité de droite du Sénat et le
gouvernement il concerne les éoliennes
offshore puisque les sénateurs proposent
de repousser à 40 km des côtes ces
éoliennes offshore est-ce que vous
comprenez les arguments de ceux qui
estiment que plein d'éoliennes sur notre
littoral bien ça pose quand même un
problème de pollution visuelle
mais je non encore une fois c'est une
mesure 40 km parce que je crois que la
ligne d'horizon est à 33 km et donc du
coup ça serait une manière de m'en aller
voir ou de ne pas les voir mais il y a
un moment c'est pas acceptable ça paraît
pour nous si on reste sur cette position
là on ne pourra pas voter ce texte c'est
évident ça fait partie ça il y en a une
rouge que vous mettez en gros ça bloque
la quasi majorité des programmes et des
projets offshore sur notre sur notre
territoire donc c'est c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible mais ça je compris on
va passer à au sujet alors du jour à
l'Assemblée l'autre sujet c'était la loi
Love Me Gérald Darmanin a présenté son
texte au député de la commission des
lois un projet de loi à 15 milliards
d'euros qui prévoit notamment de
moderniser les moyens des forces de
l'ordre en mettant le paquet sur la
lutte contre la cybercriminalité
explication Marco pommier
c'était une promesse du candidat Macron
le budget du ministère de l'Intérieur
augmentera de 15 milliards d'euros d'ici
2026 objectif pour Gérald Darmanin faire
face aux crises qui touchent le pays à
commencer par les troubles à l'ordre
public c'est fini les manifestations à
la papa c'est fini le fait que nous
puissions tous
considérer que nous connaissons par
avance qui va manifester nous devons
désormais faire face à des
manifestations spontanées numériques peu
prévisible le projet de loi vise à
renforcer la présence des forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain avec la création
de 8500 postes de policiers et de
gendarmes adopté en commission des lois
aussi le quasi doublement des places en
centre de rétention administrative pour
les étrangers en situation irrégulière
3000 places sont prévues en 2027 contre
1300 aujourd'hui je suis même certain
qu'on ne peut pas rester en état parce
que c'est rendre impuissante notre
politique d'éloignement
on a besoin d'éloignement on a besoin
d'éloignement pour les étrangers
délinquants ou criminels qui n'ont plus
leur place sur le territoire national
autre mesure la généralisation des
amendes forfaitaires pour certains
délits comme l'usage de drogue ou la
conduite sans permis le texte renforce
aussi les sanctions contre les outrages
sexistes jusqu'à 3750 euros d'amende si
ils ont lieu dans un taxi ou voiture
avec chauffeur quant aux violences intra
familiales le gouvernement veut
généraliser la possibilité de déposer
plainte en ligne avec l'application ma
sécurité il est à craindre que ce soit
un modèle de dépôt de plainte qui
deviennent en fait le seul moyen de
déposer plainte faute d'accès à les
services de police judiciaire sur les 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires plus
de la moitié des crédits seront
consacrés à la lutte contre la
cybercriminalité avec une plateforme le
17 cyber pour signaler en direct les
tentatives d'escroquerie en ligne
Guillaume Gontard à l'Assemblée
nationale comme au Sénat les écologistes
sont plutôt contre ce projet de loi Love
Me pourquoi s'opposer à une augmentation
des moyens de des forces de l'ordre il
n'y a pas d'idéologie anti-poisses
d'abord évidemment on a voté nous au
Sénat et je pense que les gars
l'Assemblée nationale contre contre ce
texte par contre on a voté la ligne
budgétaire
on l'a voté évidemment évidemment qu'on
a besoin qu'on a besoin d'argent on a
besoin même et on a besoin d'hommes et
de femmes sur le sur le terrain par
contre
sur la ligne budgétaire et sur
l'orientation budgétaire j'aurais
jusqu'à 2027 évidemment qu'on soutient
et que on a besoin on a besoin de
beaucoup plus de moyens par contre c'est
la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
de ces moyens là et quelle est
l'orientation de notre de notre police
et là effectivement on voit qu'on a des
lignes très différentes entre ce que
peut définir Gérald Darmanin et le
gouvernement à la fois sur la question
du tout numérique de du tout sécuritaire
alors que nous on dit qu'on a besoin
d'une police et de renouer le lien entre
les Françaises les Français et leur
police et que ça pour l'instant c'est
pas traité je note aussi qu'on a évacué
tous les sujets tabou du contrôle
officiel d'autres aspects sur lequel
nous on dit juste regardons on peut pas
dire que oui il y a on peut juste dire
qu'il y a des problèmes il y a des
problèmes il faut les regarder il faut
voir comment problème de menaces des
libertés individuelles des libertés
individuelles évidemment et de voir
comment on peut les on peut les régler
et c'est notre responsabilité et c'est
la responsabilité on a on est
profondément républicain on a besoin
d'une police républicaine et dont on
doit être exigeant et particulièrement
exigeant et c'est vrai que pendant tout
ce débat ça a été un peu agaçant et je
l'avais dit à Gérald dahmanen en gros
toujours avec sa manière simpliste
d'aborder les choses c'est que d'un côté
il y a les Gentils qui aiment la police
puis de l'autre côté il y a les méchants
qui n'aiment pas leur police non encore
une fois on est tous républicains on a
besoin d'une police mais on a besoin
d'être exigeant avec cette police et les
mesures qui ont été que vous qui ont été
listées là dans dans le reportage mais
je vois bien enfin je veux dire soit
d'augmenter des places en centre de de
rétention on ne règle aucun problème et
on le sait c'est pas un bon amendement
c'est un amendement venu d'érections
actuel toute façon court derrière les
propositions du rassemblement national
ça revient d'ailleurs à ce qu'on ce
qu'on pouvait dire est-ce qu'on pouvait
dire au début je vois que géralda Manin
et son orgueille en disant vous avez vu
le nombre de d'amande forfaitaire qu'on
a pu mettre sur le cannabis oui très
bien mais ce qu'on a réglé le problème
est-ce qu'on a réglé le problème de la
consommation des jeunes sur le cannabis
qui est la plus forte des pays européens
est-ce qu'on a réglé le problème des
réseaux qui sont un vrai problème et un
vrai fléau dans nos villes non et on
voit bien qu'il faut réorienter les
choses que sur la question notamment du
cannabis effectivement il va falloir
parler de légalisation parce qu'on sait
très bien que c'est une fuite en avant
et que ça on a absolument pas à
l'égalisation du cannabis bah évidemment
en tout cas il faut que le débat s'ouvre
puisque on voit bien que la question de
des mafia qui tourne autour de de ce de
ce produit c'est c'est un vrai un vrai
problème et qu'il faut aborder les
choses autrement pourquoi on n'a pas de
politique de prévention justement parce
que c'est interdit donc on a nécessité
d'avoir une vraie politique de
prévention sur sur le sur le cannabis et
donc d'avoir de légaliser pour pouvoir
mieux encadrer c'est évident Guillaume
le temps file sur cette partie autour du
projet de loi dans l'audition de Gérard
de Darmanin cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale et bien il a évoqué les
provocations de certains élus
écologistes qui étaient présents le
week-end dernier à sainte-solin dans le
département des Deux-Sèvres dans une
manifestation contre les méga bassines
c'est réservoirs d'eau destiné à
l'irrigation des terres agricoles une
manifestation qui était interdite avec
des militants écologistes dont certains
ont été violents envers les forces de
l'ordre c'était la place des élus
écologistes dans cette manifestation
mais évidemment j'ai à la première
provocation d'abord c'est les paroles de
Gérald damin sur ce qu'il a dit echo
terrorisme je veux dire le terrorisme
quand même faut enfin dire vous replacer
les mots là où ils sont je pense que
c'est une atteinte d'ailleurs à toutes
les victimes du terrorisme non je pense
qu'il faut arrêter avec ce type c'est
une insulte il faut arrêter avec ce type
de provocation je dirais qui n'a aucun
sens des fois je me demande en fait ce
que je cherche Gérald Darmanin si ce
n'est de d'attiser comme ça c'est c'est
tensions et la l'autre provocation c'est
quoi c'est d'avoir interdit justement
cette manifestation il est légitime que
des gens c'est pas rien ce qui est en
train de se passer avec ses bassines ce
qu'on a l'impression que voilà c'est
quelques quelques piscines c'est quand
même une orientation je vais dire des
des bassines qui sont gigantesques qui
mettent la main sur notre bien commun et
sur l'eau donc c'est légitime qu'on ait
des gens qui se disent ben non je pense
pas que ça soit la bonne orientation et
qui ait besoin de et besoin de
manifester je pense qu'on est en France
le droit de manifester il existe et il
faut vraiment se poser la question
pourquoi cette manifestation a été
interdite et de la manière dont elle a
été gérée si on regarde de nos voisins
européens
ils arrivent à faire des manifestations
qui se passent correctement on n'utilise
pas des bombes lacrymogènes attirent
larigot du LBD etc tout le temps donc on
voit bien qu'il y a une vraie question
sur la gestion de ces manifestations on
va passer à la suite on va parler de la
réforme des retraites puisque le budget
de la Sécurité sociale est examiné la
semaine prochaine au Sénat dans
l'hémicycle et la majorité de droite et
du centre du Sénat va proposer sa propre
réforme des retraites à travers un
amendement on va écouter le sénateur les
républicains René Paul Savary qui est
rapporteur du budget de l'assurance
vieillesse
pour éviter que les générations futures
travaillent jusque 65 ans et bien il est
nécessaire que dès à présent en prennent
un certain nombre de mesures pour
équilibrer ce système c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons
proposé une conférence réunissant les
partenaires sociaux
un an de délais pour la discussion et
s'ils ne se mette pas d'accord nous
avons des mesures paramétriques que nous
proposons que nous leur soumettons à
savoir le décalage de l'âge de départ en
retraite de 62 à 64 ans sauf bien sûr
les dérogations habituelles et la prise
en compte d'un certain nombre de
dispositifs l'accélération de la réforme
un maintien de l'âge à 60 ans le départ
quel que soit les délais de de travail
donc de cotisations et un alignement
progressif des régimes spéciaux sur ce
décalage
est-ce que vous comprenez les arguments
de la droite sanatoriale qui estiment
qu'il faut repousser l'âge de départ à
la retraite pour équilibrer notre
système ouais je comprends je comprends
surtout que les républicains et la
majonnaise sanatoriale je dirais une
c'est plus trop où elle habite
je pense qu'ils n'ont plus l'épaisseur
d'une feuille à papier de différence
avec ce que propose le gouvernement ils
nous ont fait le coup l'année dernière
et je crois l'année précédente avec un
amendement sur le passage de l'âge de la
retraite à 65 ans cette année il voulait
le faire et puis en fait le gouvernement
annonce un texte donc il se dit bon on
va quand même le faire parce que de
toute façon on n'a rien d'autre à dire
mais je veux dire que enfin à quoi ça
rime un on sait très bien que ce sujet
important sur la question des retraites
déjà sur la méthode ne peut pas passer
via un amendement comme ça donc pour moi
c'est encore une fois irresponsable le
gouvernement a annoncé un texte soit
donc je veux dire à un moment donné a
tendance ce texte-là et et discutons-en
mais voilà et puis après sur le fond je
dirais on voit bien qu'on est dans
quelque chose de totalement on veut
prolonger de aller jusqu'à 65 ans quand
on sait que les seniors de 60 à 65 ans à
plus de 50% sont au chômage ou touche
des prestations sociales on avait fait
le calcul et c'est pas moi c'est plutôt
des organismes plutôt plutôt à droite et
qui disent que cette réforme pourrait
rapporter on va dire à peu près 7
milliards elle coûte elle coûterait elle
coûte en tout cas en prestation sociale
de ces gens qui du coup serait au
chômage pendant ces cette période 6565
ans 5 milliards donc on voit bien qu'on
est dans quelque chose qui de toute
façon en plus financièrement ne rapporte
pas on sait bien qu'il y a pas d'urgence
il y a pas d'urgence pour vous il y a
pas de problème mathématiques arithmique
alors il y a pour moi explosion pour moi
il y a des problèmes alors ça le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites le dit très
bien il n'y a pas ni d'urgence ni à long
terme on sait très bien qu'on qu'on
redeviendra bénéficiaire par contre il y
a des vrais problèmes sur la pénibilité
du travail on prend sur la question du
travail sur la question du travail des
femmes aujourd'hui à partir de 9h10 vous
travaillez gratuitement madame euh ben
voilà je pense que ça c'est des vrais
sujets ça c'est des vrais sujets sur
lequel on doit qu'on doit qu'on doit
pointer et j'aimerais peut-être par
exemple que les LR et nous on en aura et
des amendements plutôt sur ces questions
là que franchement cette espèce de
bataille entre les LR et la majorité et
la majorité actuelle et où sont lesquels
on a plus de différence d'en reparler et
on va finir avec un coup d'œil à
l'agenda de la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée au Sénat
[Musique]
lundi dessinateurs commenceront donc
l'examen du budget de la Sécurité
sociale dans l'hémicycle de la rotation
blé mercredi François Molins le
procureur de la Cour de cassation est
auditionné au Sénat sur la réforme de la
police judiciaire vivement critiquée par
les policiers et les magistrats et à
l'Assemblée lundi 7 novembre plus de
budget 2023 en revanche à l'agenda le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui intègre notamment les mesures du
bouclier énergétique du gouvernement et
le 9 novembre 9h30 audition de Jean
Castex le prochain PDG de la RATP c'est
la fin de cette émission merci Guillaume
gantard d'y avoir participé et merci de
l'avoir suivi
[Musique]